bajaur a cartonné vous avez un coup de
griffe sur les douze coups de minuit
parce que depuis le 20 janvier
si vous avez regardé l'émission
l'épreuve finale avec l'étoile magique a
changé avant il y avait une photo
sérieuse est magique c'est pareil et
vous faire dire que les jours passés ont
dévoilé un petit bout de la photo et est
donc j'apprends c'est tout bête et je me
renseigne jean kate est apparemment
avant en mettant juste un bout de la
photo dévoilée
grâce à l'indicé l'intéressé soit le
système a personne qui est tombée google
images
voilà on pouvait retrouver la photo
ouais donc vous pouvez connaître le nom
de l'invité fin de l'étoile mystérieuse
voilà donc ça pose une question oui
laquelle en fait moi je vais vous les
posez la question qu'est-ce que je
m'emballe acquiesce
dans cette émission les candidats se
succèdent et gagnent beaucoup d'argent
et gagne et on gagne des belles vitrines
si on peut obtenir la vitrine en
trichant moi ça me pose un problème je
fais mais je vois desquels nous prêter
le jeune moi ça me dérange donc non mais
c'est vrai donc grâce à google images on
pourrait refouler alors j'ai calé
maintenance et non pas sa surprise parce
que ma plaie qui l'étoile mystérieuse
nom de 30 personnes que je connais
effectivement maintenant il ya des
photos qui sont en fait des créations de
shine qui donc producteurs qui donne des
indices sur la personnalité à retrouver
donc c'était plus possible d'accrocher
dit quand j'ai posé la question est
est-ce de la triche on m'a dit non
si les gens sont plus malins ah oui et
amiens se servent d'un programme pour
trouver la magic mystérieuse peu importe
à vrai dire eh ben oui elle a donc
appris que pour moi oui il ya un peu de
prix shopping c'est pas c'est pas si
grave
ceddat c'est à manille voilà c'est à
marie non mais oui mais non
l'intéressé non mais qu'est ce que vous
voulez dire
ferry est ce que tu as fait un bon sens
tu as que les gens gagnent plus de
buffle moi ça va je regarde les temps
mystérieux ne gagne pas plus qu'avant
mais qui connaît la photo pour trouver
la réponse est plus facile quand il
n'est plus là mais la voilà là on a
perdu les faits une belle enquête mais
elle va tout [ __ ] alors vous si c'est
pour dire est belle votre enquête
maintenant alors vous allez voir c'est
grave parce que j'accuse benjamin
castaldi ses amis producteurs en herbe
locaux jean luc reichmann est mis à
votre enquête elle est complètement
bidon
vous accusez les gens tout simplement de
faire ce que vous ne faites jamais c'est
à dire de travailler
ibos j'en ai jamais y travaillent c'est
comme si vous disiez aux gens qui
gagnent aux chiffres et aux lettres vous
avez lu le dictionnaire ou vous avez
révisé les tables de multiplication des
tours ib bruyant bruyant rapide et son
intérêt c'est ce beethoven qui parle
ouais ya dix ans je vous dis que c'est
n'importe quoi
mais non non pas du tout il faut quand
on lit le dictionnaire quand honda est
lui évidemment on vient on se cultive
juste part a procédé on arrive à savoir
qu'à égaler la personne mais on cherche
pour gagner ce qu'il veut
en même temps vous pouvez dire des
choses vraies une fois sur dix en vie la
fois sur dix autant là c'est une énorme
connerie 16e mauvaise intervention
benfica c'est vrai et c'est parce que
sada a révélé me rappeler qui s'est le
plus grand gagnant il a gagné huit cent
mille euros il a fait 193 adaptait ses
émissions il a révélé dans télé loisirs
avoir formellement triche et non pas des
rennais qui l'avait trouvé michel
galabru une de ses fameuses étoiles
michel galabru grâce justement internet
et ben voila quoi donc mis la pression
je sais pas de là ce n'est pas la triste
la malice c'est le jeu qui est mal
construites sur moi voilà franchement
vous répondez moi vraiment en votre âme
et conscience de mon coeur qui
s'intéresse ce débat pas moi moi je
m'emballe est vraiment pas ma mère oui
ah oui mais tu es qui l'annoncé ce débat
c'est moi
[Applaudissements]
mentalement on est vraiment